all right lots of great stuff happening
including this have you ever wanted to
get up close and personal with a big old
truck yeah well for kids it's a dream
come true for a lot of them certainly
this weekend you can get that chance in
downtown Summerlin and that's where we
have Candace Charles live this morning
with Touch a Truck Candace good morning
to you
good morning guys
uh can touch here thank you Damien at
the Touch a Truck Event here in downtown
Summerlin it's bought by a family of
family connections it really is the gift
that keeps on a giving and I have
Jillian Batista here with me from tattoo
shop thank you so much for joining us
tell us a little bit about how this will
benefit family and family connections
sure so all funds raised from Touch a
Truck will go directly to family to
family connection which is local
non-profit in town that provides free
learning resources and Child Development
classes to families in our community
amazing thank you for what you're doing
in the community we appreciate it and
you know you'll get the chance to really
see the folks behind the wheel in this
event so family event a lot of people
look forward to Damon Schilling here the
AMR paramedic has done this quite a few
times what can people expect I come out
and see the inside of an ambulance and
really understand what an ambulance is
all about with a low or no stress
situation we got stickers for the kids
we got a lot of other fun things for
them as well amazing that sounds like
it's going to be a great time thank you
as well for all you doing the community
we appreciate you guys as you can see
lots of different types of trucks will
be out here here on Saturday from nine
to two now if you have some kiddos who
don't really like all of the noise
there'll be a lot of horns and
everything's out here they're going to
have a horn free part of the event from
nine to ten of course the tickets are
fairly cheap guys it's eight bucks
online 12 at the door kids two and under
are free more details on our website
eightnewsnow.com coming up we're gonna
be checking out some more of these
trucks hanging out with these guys so
you guys won't want to miss it for now
live from downtown Summerlin I'm Candace
Charles 8 News Now